Have you heard about or done any research on hydrogen-rich water?
It's been shown to be beneficial in mitigating oxidative stress,
induced damage through its anti-inflammatory and apoptonic pathways,
helping cardiovascular health, liver health, and even mental health?
Yes, so I've heard a lot about that.
And we've talked about this before.
So I have no trouble with hydrogen-rich water.
I don't see any contraindicative studies,
nor evidence just thinking about the physiology towards cancer.
So there are certain things that are fine to do,
but if if cancer they're not so fine to do,
no hydrogen-rich water, hydrogenated water,
there's hydrogenators, machines that you can purchase that will hydrogenate water for you.
You can put hydrogen tablets in water and let's say a bottle of water and shake it up.
And that's how you can get hydrogen water.
It's been popular for a long time.
There's Dr. Halder-Manouis to work for me years ago,
some of you may remember her.
She is a rep for a company on a floor that sells bottles that hydrogenate to your water,
I believe.
So they can be good things, it can be good for you,
so it's another thing that can be good for you.